-Our next guest
is a talented actor
who stars in the Netflix series
"The Woman in the House
Across the Street
from the Girl in the Window."
All eight episodes
will be available to stream
on Netflix starting tomorrow.
Let's take a look.
-Is there anything I can do?
-Like what?
-Build a time machine
so you can go back in time
and change things.
-Hi, Anna.
-Hi, Emma.
-All right.
We should go.
It's good seeing you.
-W-Wait, one second.
I want you to have this.
Life is for the living.
And so are casseroles.
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome to the show
Tom Riley, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How are you, Tom?
-I'm good, I'm good.
Thank you.
-I'm very happy
to have you here.
Your talented wife,
the actress Lizzy Caplan,
has been here in the past.
She's back in the green room.
It was lovely to see her.
-Thank you.
When my name is mentioned,
when she says
that she's married to me,
the type of applause
that I get -- that she gets
is more the sort of,
"Oh, well done. You've fostered
an old stray dog."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But that --
She deserves that.
She's the best.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-Yeah, it's right.
They're like,
"That's so sweet of you, Lizzy,
to have done that."
-Yeah, thank you.
-How are you guys doing?
-We're good.
We --
We just had a baby.
-You did!
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, is this one of these --
Is this one of these
secret babies?
-Yeah, I mean, we say --
Yeah, I say we just had a baby.
It was -- It was about
4 1/2 months ago.
Someone else said --
the other day they said,
"Is this -- Did you do this --
Was this a secret pregnancy?"
And, I mean, not on purpose.
-Yeah.
-It's just we didn't --
We didn't tell anyone.
It's not like we --
we snuck Lizzy into the hospital
under a blanket,
and then, two days later,
we, like, emerge with a baby
hidden in a bowling-ball bag.
We just -- We just --
No one asked.
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
-So we just, you know --
-Well, congratulations.
Have you -- how has fatherhood
treated you so far?
-It is -- It's good.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. It's --
No, it's great.
-You know what?
I'm sorry.
"Good" is the honest answer,
and I really appreciated it.
-Thank you, thank you.
-Let's not go crazy.
-It has its ups and downs.
And at 4 months old,
they are, you know...
-They're a little something.
-There's not a lot going on.
-No, well, that's the thing.
And we had him in London.
-Mm-hmm.
-But we -- Yeah, so we
flew back here
when he was 3 months old.
And have you --
You've just had --
-Yeah, but we have not
put her on an airplane yet.
-Have you done an international
flight with a young...?
-Not that young.
No, that's young, too.
-Everyone said to us,
"It's young, but it's okay.
They're gonna sleep
the whole way."
-Right.
-That is not true.
[ Laughter ]
And the thing about babies --
I don't know.
This may come
as a surprise to you,
but they [bleep] themselves...
[ Laughter ]
...and they don't care
where they are.
-Right.
-They don't care if they're
on the ground
or if they're in the air.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-But we were so prepared.
We had, like, a go bag.
-Yes.
-Like doomsday preppers.
It was, like, full of, like,
diapers and everything.
But we put it up
in the overhead compartment.
And what no one said is that,
on takeoff,
it's not just their ears
that pop.
[ Laughter ]
It's also their buttholes.
That's right.
And so we get to like
5,000 feet, and he looks at us,
and he just sort of goes
that kind of red
from the neck up
that means he's, like...
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-...cooking a fresh batch
or something.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And we're just like,
"Don't you -- Don't you --
Not now. Don't --"
And he just -- bfff!
[ Laughter ]
I mean, like --
like a confetti cannon.
[ Laughter ]
Like, we're celebrating
something awful.
And it goes, like,
through his --
through his clothes,
through his diaper.
Like, somehow
it's in his hair instantly.
And everyone around us
is going like, "Oh, no.
Oh, no, no."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-"We're stuck on the plane
with this baby."
And I don't know.
I felt like this may not be the
case for you, but, like, I --
Being a new daddy, there's
a lot of feeling very useless.
-Yes, 100%.
-Most of the beginning.
-Yeah.
-And so anytime I can see a job
that I can do, I'm like,
"That's -- I'm here.
I'm ready."
-Oh, that's very noble, yeah.
-And I felt like,
"Operation Clean Up --
I've got this."
-Yeah.
-And the minute those seatbelt
signs go out, I am going to --
I'm gonna get these guys
to the bathroom.
So, I'm there like, "8,000 feet,
9,000 feet, 10,000 feet."
Seatbelts --
the seatbelt sign goes out.
I'm, like, up on the aisle.
"Make way!
Lady with -- lady with baby!
Lady with a stinky baby!"
And --
And we go into the bathroom.
Oh, she's gonna kill me
for telling this,
I've just realized, this story.
[ Laughter ]
Um...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Well, it's not like -- it's not
like you're that far into it.
-No, you're right.
You're right.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
And -- And so we get in there,
or Lizzy goes in ahead,
and she puts Alfie --
is our son -- down on the --
on the toilet, basically, 'cause
it's a tiny airplane bathroom.
I try and get in there.
I can't get in.
Like, "What can I do?
How can I help?"
And she's like, "Just stay --
stay on the door.
Make sure no one comes in.
It can't lock.
Just stay there."
I'm like, "I've got it.
Daddy's here.
Everybody's safe."
And I stand there
thinking I'm gonna be
an impenetrable wall.
And then, the seatbelt sign
comes back on.
[ Laughter ]
and I'm a stickler
for the rules.
[ Laughter ]
You know, especially the rules
of -- the law of the sky.
-Sure, of course.
They can pull
your flight status.
-Exactly. And anyone could've
been an air marshal.
-Right.
-I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
And so I was like,
"Well, if I go back down,
no one's gonna --
no one's gonna come and --"
-Right.
-"The seatbelt sign's on.
No one's gonna interrupt her.
So I went, and I sat,
and I unclip --
clipped my belt back on.
And I look,
and this guy gets up, and he
starts to walk to the thing,
and I'm like, "Don't, don't,
don't, no, no, no, no, no!"
And he opens the door,
and he gasps, and Lizzy --
I can still --
I can still see it.
Like, because of the way
she's positioned,
she's on all fours,
and she's got, like,
poop up her arms,
maybe a little bit on her face.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And because of the way
she's there on all fours
in front of the toilet,
you can't even see the baby.
[ Laughter ]
And it -- it just looks like
she's eating out of the toilet.
[ Laughter ]
And, I mean, I felt embarrassed.
I felt regret.
-Yeah.
-I felt like I was --
I hadn't protected my family.
-Did you feel like opening
the door and just jumping?
-Yeah!
But that was the thing.
I'm stuck.
I can't escape.
I say there's nowhere I can go.
My wife's mad at me.
And that is basically what being
a dad feels like it's all about.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-The effort!
The fact that you made
the effort.
Real quick,
because I will not --
I had to read it off cue cards.
So, this show that you're in
with Kristen Bell,
which is a sort of parody
of sorts of this kind of
crime thriller that we've
sort of fallen in love with
the last few years, how --
Can you say the title
real quick,
and how long did it take you
to learn it?
-"The Woman in the House
Across the Street
from the Girl in the Window"?
-Yeah.
-We had a little head start
because it was called
"The Woman in the House"
when we were shooting it,
and that's sort of 40%.
So when they added the rest,
I already had that
in my back pocket.
-Right.
-It was down, yeah.
-Well, it's really fun.
And you and Kristen
are great together, and thank
you so much for being here.
What a pleasure to have you.
-Oh, such a pleasure.
-You guys, that's Tom Riley.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"The Woman in the House
Across the Street
from the Girl in the Window"
is available to stream
on Netflix starting tomorrow.